في المقابل انتقد المندوب الروسي في مجلس
الامن
فاسيليا انتقد مواقف الدول الغربيه ازاء
قرار روسيا نقل اسلحه النوويه تكتيكيه الى
بيلاروسيا وقال ان الخطوه لا تنتهك
التزامات روسيا الدوليه فيما يتعلق بعدم
انتشار الاسلحه النوويه
النشر
لشركائنا الغربيين السابقين وهو ان روسيا
مسؤوله عن كل العلل في عالم اليوم لكننا
نتحدث هنا عن امور خطيره تؤثر في امن
كوكبنا باكمله نتعاون مع بيلاروسيا دون
انتهاك التزاماتنا الدوليه فيما يتعلق
بعدم انتشار الاسلحه النوويه الرئيس بوتين
كان واضحا بشان حقيقه اننا لا نتحدث عن
نقل اسلحه نوويه نحن نتحدث عن نقل مجمعات
الصواريخ التكتيكيه التشغيليه الى
بيلاروسيا وصواريخ اسكندر واعاده تجهيز
الطائرات البيلاروسيه وبناء منشاه تخزين
خاصه للاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه على اراضي
بيلاروسيا سيكون هذا كله تحت السيطره
الروسيه